Inconsistency occurs when two different entries contradict one
another. So for example, if a customer is
recorded in two different current addresses, we've got
a consistency problem. Fixing consistency problems really boils down
to the problem of who do I trust
the most, or more specifically, which data source do
I trust the most? So with our address
example, we might ask ourselves which entry was collected
most recently. or if our problem is one that's
a little more general say just location information. Another type
of question we can ask is which collection method
is likely to be most reliable? Because one data source
might be populated based on GPS while another is
based on user enter data. We might actually have a
third that's using IP based location detection and all
three of these are contributing location information to our system.
So again, addressing consistency problems is about determining which
of our data sources is most likely to be correct.
And possibly introducing agreement among our inconsistent records by
copying the data from the record we trust the most.